welcome to this video playing horrible
bets haro bets from the US a news oh
yeah I'm trying a couple of new lines
now is playing my own line the Zurich
variation interesting hmm castles well
that's very uncommon hmm I wonder why
actually there's some big drawback to
that no I don't I don't really know
I can just take age 7 Jack you wonder
went what the point is okay um so I'm
yeah I can also just castle now why not
is there I can just castle here thread
95 yeah probably should take c3m
30 95 so he has to take C 3 okay I'm
across here efore I take f6 and take
before so that would be two pawns and
this I overlooked how stupid is that why
didn't I think of this but ok ok I'm ok
let's not let's not be too pessimistic
about it maybe I can really try to make
this work with 92 94 these kind of
things on with F for using this pin what
am I doing here this is this is really
idiotic ok King takes 90 for this Bishop
f5 am Bishop f6 hm king edge 7f form
King edge 7f form now can just play you
for I can just take them to the bishop
IAM night inform Bishop f5 bishop f6
Bishop takes e4 Bishop e7 Bishop see to
Bishop f8 and he just has a good
position okay King takes there's some
way to make this work you know I didn't
I just set off castle i can just retreat
the bishop bandit it's just just yeah
okay you can just take h7 now I mean
what what exactly is the problem f4e
form or is there some some sort of some
trick that I don't see
be sure ice bishop king cakes 94 bishop
at five is there something that I'm not
seeing
they can just take h7 I don't know what
he's doing yeah now we finally finally
took it f form yeah that's still the
best best chance probably F form
therefore I need to place fo I guess EF
e 4 is not good probably I don't know
even that is possibly good
it's not very necessary to do to take it
in for was just much simpler whatever he
just blend us h7 and I play castles and
overlooked g6 sometimes I really think I
should should switch to some easier game
if it takes III i have f five maybe okay
not sure what this is I'm going to take
it
no I mean this is this isn't isn't so
super easily winning f5 green here this
is the scissor not not so easy not at
all and I ever have a serious attack
here check yes 95 coming
check ok so let's let's check this you
will probably take a sieve form and I
need to the Queen near the King somehow
how do i get a nice King h3 would be
good f2 h4l sssss is probably right here
and then to f2 to h4 yep f6 I have 96 ok
it's no media it's hard to believe
time morning
I want green h6 but it's got 94
this chicken Bishop h6 can calculate
this with the time check check check
check check check check mate two seconds
for what a weird game yeah I really have
heard I what am I doing here I mean he's
just blunders h7 like a little child and
then I'm totally ignoring GC yeah this
is just it's just totally totally weird
why do I castle here oops sorry check I
can do whatever ya really I can Bishop
somewhere or defy her so this is
probably easiest d5 shank something like
this back and then I'm just retreating
this piece and I just have one age 7 and
the game with no no problems whatsoever
instead I simply overlooked g6 yeah
idiotic yeah and I try to try to try
this business and now he thought for
over two minutes before he took this wow
wow
that's it's really amazing the point is
it could have played 90 for any way I
can play this anyway because after
Bishop f5 I have the exceptionally
strong move f3 Wow fantastic I didn't
see that at all wyd wins here just just
completely winning because now f6 is
really under check and he has no move
this is this is just just winning easily
and I threatened to take now i can even
let's say here i can just move the Queen
somewhere and he's in a deadly pin wow
so this is maybe he saw that and this is
why it took so long he didn't find a
move and I totally misjudged just do
anything I was thinking why isn't he
taking it what else is there and yeah so
what should he do actually then I'm
threatening 94 then you know what the
computer is giving us the best move
that's really cute nightby aid but white
is much better after year for now
takes 90 for example or takes before and
widest just a fantastic shape so this
means this what I played is actually
quite okay this g6 business because of
92 of course I wouldn't have I didn't I
didn't see that I simply didn't see f3 I
was also a bit too frustrated about the
whole thing because i had hadn't planned
all that so i went with this and he took
which is right I thought you four would
just be good look simple um maybe but ok
this is also probably probably ok but i
think it's not that that trivial to play
with the little time around here think
calf i have some sort of a tech check
maybe not enough but I computer still
gives black a win with f6 for example
this is now getting still should still
seems to be good for like check
curiously night f7 is given as a draw by
the computer or let's say minus 0.5 what
a mess check aim check and this wasn't
it wasn't any good why not actually King
g8 takes you have aa because I cannot
check on f6 because of Knight f3 yeah I
have okay the comp is a good defender
yeah and TM here white is winning but ok
it's a total mess but this was a very
cute thing with this is every move which
which which I'd simply completely
overlooked ok thanks for watching